Every year, Iceland gets wider by two centimetres.
A cow with a name will produce 450 more pints
of milk a year than one without a name.
In 2011, scientists re-measured Norway's beaches,
islands and fjords, adding 11,000 miles to
its coastline.
The labourers who built the Great Wall of
China were were fed on sauerkraut.
People who pirate music also buy more music
legally than people who don't pirate.
The human brain cannot feel pain.
Guinness isn't black; it's very dark red.
The closer a woman is to the equator, the
more likely she is to give birth to a girl.
Nicotine increases the body's metabolism of
caffeine, and therefore can reduce the impact
of caffeine's effects.
The average London pigeon has 1.6 feet.
If you stood on the Martian equator at noon,
it would feel like summer at your feet and
winter at your head.
You can tell if someone is yawning from their
eyes alone.
The 25th November 2012 was the first day since
1960 that there was no murder or manslaughter
in New York City.
In ancient Rome, fathers had the legal right
to kill their children.
German mothers-to-be are said to have 'roast
dinners' not 'buns' in their 'ovens'.
According to the Mayan calendar, the next
time the 'world is going to end' is 3rd May
7138.